Question on methylene blue. Do you recommend it and its use orally or otherwise?
Thank you very much. God bless you. They're so polite. I know that there's other doctors out there that really push some different products like methylene blue is pushed by Dr.
Bacola really big. Honestly I'm not a fan and I'll tell you why because methylene blue is is a methyl donor so okay so to understand that is that we pick up methyl groups a methyl group in chemistry is a carbon with three hydrogens attached to it and it's an ion and attaches to things quite easily.
It is necessary in our body. We need methyl groups. We make methyl groups through pathway through what's called our folate pathway and then through the methanine pathway. These are two metabolic pathways in our body. These are two pathways that we assess when we do a full genetic workup on somebody.
Well a lot of doctors that do a genetic workup on somebody have a I don't know how to say this nice but they don't have a like a real deep understanding of what they're doing with their they think that they're treating gene defects.
So a real common thing that effect there's there's even Facebook groups that talk about the defect in a specific gene family called the MTHFR gene. So and there's been like there's people that feel like they're cursed because they have an MTHFR gene defect like like there's somehow defective people and they have all sorts of problems with everything in life now.
This is just so untrue. So the treatment for this is they get on excess methyl groups. They typically jump they get on or their practitioner puts them on methyl cobalamine, which is a methyl type of B12 and they put them on methyl folate, which is methyl tetrahedral folate.
Which those things aren't bad. Those things are found in nature. If you eat a lot of green leafy vegetables, you're getting a natural form of folate.
But the problem is that we're taking a bioptic view of that and we're not looking at all the genetics. If you start taking a whole bunch of excess methyl groups and understand that the question of taking methylene blue, that's going to be that's adding a whole bunch more excess methyl groups.
You can also push another pathway called your bioptor and pathway. And if you have defects on that pathway, especially the serotonin genes, you're going to push out excess serotonin. And that's not going to be good. You're going to end up having issues from that.
So I would just be careful jumping on a supplement bandwagon without really taking a good assessment of your whole body. Now, somebody that doesn't have any defects or very few defects in their bioptor and pathway, would probably be able to get on fairly high dose of methyl folate.
But I've seen time and time again, where people will call me and have a case review and they're like, I had a doctor said I had an MTHFRG defect put me on methyl folate. This is before methylene blue is big. And I've just got these issues now anger and I just can't control it.
Well, you look at their full genetic profile. They got defects in their bioptor pathway. They're just spilling out too much serotonin and they can have a lot of aggression issues and just emotional imbalances because those are neurotransmitters.
And you want to look at the whole big picture. It's just kind of like treating somebody with just a little snippet of objective data. You want to try to get as much objective data and some objective data before you put together a treatment protocol that can alter things and maybe over correct if you think that's the right terminology.
And so I'd be careful about that. So personally, I don't use methylene blue and I don't recommend it for people.
And part of the is to do it, we see a lot of people with a cancer diagnosis. So you don't want excess methyl groups when you have a cancer diagnosis, especially because one of the things that methyl groups do is they silence genes.
You don't want to have any excess silencing of tumor suppressor genes because that is your key defensive strategy from an intercellular function for you to be able to kill cancer cells.
And when you have silenced tumor suppressor genes, you're hindering your body's ability to cause apoptosis to a growing cancer mass.
So I got a big fan of excess methyl groups, especially with cancer patients.
The only time I'll recommend methyl groups is you look at a person's, you get more data, right?
So I don't recommend methyl groups just based upon a person's genes, you don't treat gene defects.
But it's beneficial to, you know, you do want to give methyl groups to a person who has elevated homocystines.
And that's not going to be followed through genetics, that's going to be followed through a complete metabolic panel with a person that's elevated homocystine you want to add methyl groups.
And it might only be temporarily until you bring that down and don't support that pathway.